The last season of Game of Thrones was always
going to feature plenty of death, destruction,
and chaos, and it certainly didn't disappoint
with its penultimate episode, "The Bells,"
which focuses almost entirely on the long-awaited
siege of King's Landing.
With the end in sight, the series still has
plenty of plots left to conclude, and it moved
closer than ever to the endgame.
With the final episode just a week away, the
show is offing major characters left and right
- let's dive into who didn't win the Game
of Thrones this time around.
Obviously gigantic spoilers ahead.
Lord Varys has been one of the most mysterious
figures on Game of Thrones throughout its
run.
The best gossip in the Seven Kingdoms, Varys
quietly pulled the strings in the background
for much of the show's eight seasons, even
as many of the main characters surrounding
him thought they were calling the shots.
Until the very end, Varys was consistent and
pragmatic about who might be the best ruler
of the Seven Kingdoms.
And once he found out that Jon Snow had a
stronger claim to the Iron Throne than Daenerys
Targaryen, he went against the Dragon Queen,
knowing that doing so would immediately put
himself at risk.
In trying to do what was best for the Seven
Kingdoms, The Spider signs his own death warrant,
and finds himself at the mercy of Daenerys.
Unfortunately for him, she has little to no
mercy left to spare, and Varys dies by flame,
the latest victim of the word:
"Dracarys."
Game of Thrones has been quietly laying tracks
for Daenerys to follow in her unstable father's
footsteps for quite some time, but the Dragon
Queen's pivot to Mad Queen still seems quite
abrupt, even for a woman who's made a habit
of burning her enemies.
By the beginning of the fifth episode, Daenerys
is utterly despondent, having lost two dragons
as well as two of her closest friends and
confidantes Jorah Mormont and Missandei.
She seems to have lost her compass, and she
spends some of the episode's earlier moments
threatening her Queen's Hand, Tyrion Lannister,
as well as trying to rekindle the romance
she had with Jon Snow before they learned
his secret royal lineage makes him a more
compelling contender for the Throne - as well
as the fact that she's his aunt.
Jon, although visibly conflicted, rejects
her romantic advances - probably because,
well, she's his aunt - a rejection that steels
Daenerys for her vengeful path.
Even though the bells of King's Landing ring
soon after Daenerys' first assault to signal
a full surrender to their new queen, she shows
no mercy to the city.
She sets both soldiers and civilians ablaze
in an ugly, horrific move that exhibits the
worst of her family's infamous impulses.
Without her trusted advisors, Daenerys has
run amok, and just to make everything worse,
she's massacred thousands of innocents in
the process.
With so many citizens of King's Landing dying
in her assault, Queen Daenerys may not have
many people to actually rule when she finally
takes whatever's left of the throne.
It seems that Varys was right to have backed
Jon Snow after all...
One of the show's most highly anticipated
moments finally arrives in "The Bells."
We're talking, of course, about the long-awaited
battle known as CleganeBowl, the final showdown
between the righteous yet savage Sandor Clegane,
known as the Hound, and his enormous, zombified
older brother Gregor, known as the Mountain.
The two finally meet in the Red Keep as Cersei
tries to mount her escape, but neither brother
gives a second thought to the Lannister queen,
who casually sidles away as the two finally
prepare to face off.
The Mountain tosses Cersei's Hand, Qyburn,
aside like a rag doll and kills him, and the
battle begins.
After a brutal fight, during which the Hound
realizes he can't simply kill this creature
who was once his brother, he tackles him as
the building collapses, leading both brothers
to fall to their deaths and providing a poignant
ending to the Clegane conflict as well as
the Hound's character arc.
The three remaining Lannisters - Jaime, Tyrion,
and Cersei - have spent the show's eight seasons
at odds with each other more often than not.
But in this episode, members of the fraught
family come back together more than once,
helping each other get through the war as
best as they can.
Before the battle begins, Tyrion frees Jaime
from captivity in his own camp, asking Jaime
to make sure the bells of surrender ring,
and convince Cersei to escape from King's
Landing in a dinghy Tyrion has arranged to
have waiting in a secret spot on the shore.
The two also share a beautifully tender moment
when Tyrion tells Jaime that he would never
have survived his childhood without him:
"You were the only one who didn't treat me
like a monster."
Jaime repays Tyrion for his help, and at his
brother's urging, tries to escape with Cersei
after he fights and murders Euron Greyjoy
so he can find his way back to her side.
But they soon discover there's no way out
as the Red Keep collapses above them.
The two meet their deaths in each other's
arms as the world falls apart around them,
proving that no matter what, the Lannisters
not only pay their debts, but stick together
until the bitter end.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Game
of Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.